I believe we're now on YouTube chair
okay thank you
so the first thing we're going to do
counselors is to do a register of
attendance so that we know when half the
voting time who's present who isn't so
the torque is going to read out the
names remember to confirm their
attendance if you do that please yes
chair coats and a bouncing yes I'm here
Tencent Brenton yes that's the bright
yep that's the brown time Thank You
Margaret close in a bush be beer
it's a craggy can so Christy Clark yeah
Edna Cottle honking yeah pencil a dart
no can't afford yeah let's look up here
heads the Hackett yeah Chancellor
Harding yeah that's my veins
yeah thanks the Hawkins yeah councillor
hippo yeah
councillor Hicks
no cancel Hudson yeah pencil Hurley yeah
councillor hutchins yeah penciler inch
here counselor James here councillor
Jones Chancellor laws yeah Kent's new
Langford here that's no leather
I don't counselor look yeah McKenzie
yeah it's the manly yeah
councillor Newton yeah councillor
Pennington yeah councillor Rossi he's on
his way
no thank you
pencil Watson yeah Samir hence the wise
men present I thank you for that and
I've got in front of me a sheet group
sheet with the the procedure for the how
we operate the night
very good attendance I have to say and
basic rules basically and all
microphones will be muted except for
mine now or some privilege of being
chair you know and leave all microphones
muted unless you're asked by myself just
there will be a public participation and
start of the meeting and procedure is
going to be followed whereby there be by
YouTube we have one person registered to
speak today would you indicate to me if
you'd like to speak or propose a second
emotion press the raise hand button a
symbol sorry on your screen in the
participants menu which is on your
screen they shall it'll come up on my
screen in order
of requests to speak so we can make sure
that everybody gets a chance and in the
correct order to ensure accuracy for
meeting all the votes will be recorded
and you'll be asked to say for or
against when your read is when your name
is read out and you're unmuted as I say
this this meeting will be broadcast on
YouTube so if you were bear with me
during this meeting I'm sure you'll be
very indulgent and in return I will with
you I hope so the first partner is
apologies for absent absence rather we
got any Sandra no apologies chair no
apologies occasion did I welcome the
people from you were on YouTube I hope I
did if I didn't I will know so good item
to them which is the council minutes or
the first one is the February the 17th
and I'll do it page by page
so it's page 1 page 2 and that's it so
we need to have a proposal seconder
their true record please somebody
well I'll have to propose sorry propose
Thank You councillor Hackett I'll second
them in so we'll just go to the vote now
and Sandra read your names
yeah sorry excuse me chair we've got
some members with their hands up
councillor Haynes counselor Hodgson and
councillor Clark hey these are two
question two minutes okay
in that order then which was the first
one again who was first one it's Lehane
it's the second set of minutes chair
sorry
oh right okay next person who was the
next person sorry until o'clock chair
hey I was just putting my hand up to
second you
in episode all right thank you very much
guys your chart all right and the third
one third one it was a third one
counselor Hodgson raised their hands but
I can't see that's still raised at
present all right okay well well in that
case we'll go to the vote and Sandro
goes through the list again
Thank You chair Kent's an about-turn or
thanks to the Brenton or that's the
bright or thanks LeBron I wasn't
abstaining from that meeting
yeah cancel it Bush be passing a bush be
you need to immediate catch the bus be
right for canceled Christy Sandra and
the dart is arrived
thank you John five times the water okay
oh go back to cancel the dart cancel it
dot I'll go I'll leave that to the end
counselor cab yeah I presume I'm
confirming minutes so I'm saying yes
Thank You counselor hack it or cancel
the harding or counselor Hames or cancel
the Hawkins
yeah I had to abstain on that one I
wasn't at that meeting abstain literally
or Henson Hutchins stain penciler inch
abstain counts no James or cancel each
owns poor there's no laws or hence no
Langford or Chancellor leather or its
new look
Oh Thank You councillor McGough or
counselor McKenzie or cancel a manly
abstaining counselor Newton Katz the
Pennington stoned counselor Rossi just
unmute yourself counselor Wasi please
now I'll work it out eventually
abstaining Anna Watson
ensign Wiseman abstain and cancel a dart
you have to commute aside case of Dart
please sorry for Thank You cancer doc
right but um counselor so that's just a
dress rehearsal for the whole council
meeting on Monday the 24th of February
so you're already up and doing for that
one though read out the pages once again
so we got page 1 page 2 there with me h3
h4 h5 yes who's that go Saints Age
forger regarding the new homes bonus and
the whole question of housing may I take
the opportunity of asking whether in the
light of the recent inspectors decision
concern
bird in Torrington that forages housing
allocation is insufficient may I suggest
this council holds a special meeting in
the very near future to discuss a review
of the local plan in order to consider
the housing allocation and other urgent
policy issues thank you right we got to
we haven't got a planning officer with
us tonight don't we don't gone if there
Shawna's there is Lee yes well without
going into the detail of what happened
at beau-word ready I think what will
councillor Haines if you send me an
email about what you would like to see
happen at such a meeting then we can
discuss that how we could go forward
with that I think I think answer that
Christie's got some ideas on that as
well actually so if you're happy with
that then we'll take you we'll take it
from there
you were right with that thank you okay
thank you that was page five I think
yeah okay you've got a couple of demos
with their hands out okay do that in
council Hawkins Christie and McGough all
right in that order
yes revoking sim please you need to tell
me your side case the Hawkins please
thank you yeah sorry it's a bit late now
I think it was Council to push me to
prompted that I was indeed at the
meeting that I said I wasn't a lot of me
Oh was it not but somebody did but it
was the second meeting on the 24th I
wasn't thank you all right thank you for
that mr. Christie thank you this on page
five item 103 yeah I brought this up
before about our investment funds and so
we have to put our money in a very
restricted series of banks come at us
because I don't know how many other
councils of notice in the last week and
the ethical funds about performed
everything else and I think we ought to
look
this I have asked before about of this
but we go back to the where we have got
our funds invested and we ask those
banks and the various companies where do
they invest our money but I think we
ought to know and I'm just wondering if
we can actually find that out thank you
thank you right thank you for that I
suppose really that's a good question
for the audit committee really well yes
Jeff I couldn't respond that's okay
there's a that the item has come to
Christy mentioned has been brought up
and it's on a forward plan for internal
all new and scrutiny to look at right
Thank You counsel Gulf hello hello chef
thank you master so mute myself there
item 106 1 minute 1 and 630 knossos
motion from collapse of the Jones oh yes
as he left being sent to stage shows
right councillor Jones can you update us
on that one if I'm the counselor says
gonna be written mr. chairman right oh
okay sorry is there any update at all
yes he was Fed chair and came to the
dome to receive their copy of what was
sent right mr. Jones equity and
lightness on what was said I mean all as
far as I'm aware and we accept the
letter and then obviously that's gone
into the consultation and they've just
released posts coded time tables now
which looked fairly reasonable so I
think that was that seems to be okay
going forwards all right well done thank
you for that
so that was page six and then page seven
so from the chair proposed we approve
those minutes they don't got a seconder
please I'll second them chair thank you
guys together so we'll go to the boat
then Sandra please Thank You Chancellor
pension for counselor Brenton or can't
celebrate
or cancel a brand obscene cancer the
Busby
Shh si platypus deeply for the Christie
car cancel Clark
oh it's little pumpkin for Chancellor
dart or pants and a forward abstain
hence look up for cancel a Hackett for
pencil Harding or heads no Hames or
cancel Hawkins yep this is all I didn't
attend solid state Thank You counselor
hippo abstain cancel Hudson
Oh Chancellor Haley or pencil Hutchins
abstain counselor inch for counselor
James or counselor Jones yeah counselor
laws or hence the Langford for Hanson
11400 counselor Mackenzie or cancel mmm
Lee or counselor Newton Kent
that's the Pennington abstain counselor
Rossi and you and me Giuseppe thanks for
watching and you I was there was i for
then if you want to change it
sorry cancel it rossi you're voting for
oh thank you
and counselor Wiseman saying thank you
can snows right thank you very much just
say rid of some of the tedious stuff
thank you there now we've got to item
number three which is public
contributions and we do have a probably
contribution don't we um John or okay I
don't I don't believe we have a public
contribution we don't I thought we did I
thought we were when we spoke before
that we had somebody wanted to
participate no no Joe that's under the
petition bit in there all right okay
fair enough I'll move on then to number
four declarations of interest so we're
you're all familiar with this and they
just declare your interest prior to the
item being discussed item six
correspondence by the chair or Steve did
you want to bring in anything at this
stage so you just missed out item five
or big apartment agreements between Part
one and Part two we have one item we
bought two okay all right I'll move the
agenda chat I'll second that chair thank
you
all in favor well we have to go through
the procedure again I'm afraid of birth
of the voting recording vote okay ready
[Music]
sorry Sandra could I just relax has just
joined the meeting alright thank you
okay
right cancel about 1000 councillor
Brenton Oh
Tencent upright or cancel a brown or
cancel Bushby or cancel Christy oh it's
a clock Oh cancel a cut of honking or
cancel a dart that's the darts under
she's not with us anymore I spoke to
earlier and she was having trouble with
our Wi-Fi right thank you
cancel afford or cancel a cab for pencil
hack it or pencil holding or pencil
Hammes
for cancer Hawkins or cancel hippo poor
cancer Hicks
you need to meet you so quaintly Hicks
please
for you thank you
cancel Hudson oh hello Hurley or
Hutchins
oh that's the wrench for pencil James or
pencil Jones or pencil in law's or
pencil in Langford for pence no leather
oh yes sandwich just everybody on that
moment the counselor and mutter under
the breath can you do so when you meet
it not when you're not yeah when you
actually live I can say soap in a public
so I go for for without peace thank you
can't see my girl can see McKenzie for
manly Oh Newton Pennington or penciler
Rossi for penciler Watson or and hence
the wise men oh thank you that unanimous
right thank you for that so now we come
on to item six in correspondence and
Steve was there something you want to
raise in this part or later I'm chair
counselor Haynes just raised his hand
sorry
next one sorry all right forefinger and
counselors we live in obviously very
troubled times at the moment and many of
you have been involved in your
communities doing a variety of things to
serve the people you represent but let's
not lose all that information it would
be good if we could have some sort of
centrioles of diary if you like of what
you as counselors have learned from the
experience and when things went right
and what things went wrong for future
references
so easy to to forget valuable lessons
learned really I know back in them in
the eighties are terrible go back to
here a time but never mind there was a
lot of talk then about emergency
procedures and how things were to be
done but that's all slipped away in the
meantime regrettably I do know possibly
will be other things that come up
equally as disastrous hopefully not but
there's there's various bugs in the
pipeline even as we speak so if you
would like to consider that and suggest
ways of how we could coordinate all
those experiences together I would
appreciate that so I'll leave that one
with you so we move on then to item
seven then okay a question he's got his
hand up or I'll be bored yep see ya
thank you and this is something I don't
know how many people have looked at
their planning application list has come
out today but there's actually an
extremely important one on there which
is going to affect us all counsel Haynes
referred earlier to the Burwood
Torrington decision where porridges lost
our local plan basically any developer
can now come along and apply there is
one on today's planning application this
to do with northern where an applicant
put in an application it was turned down
by toric he went to appeal he lost it at
appeal and exactly the same applications
being put in but quoting the Torrington
case so if any of you have had planning
applications in your ward that have
previously been turned down and even
lost that appeal they could well
suddenly come back and I think this is
something that counselors need to be
aware of when our planning officers need
to give us some steer on this because it
could be extremely important thank you
thank you for that well as it says in
there in the procedure for Cobra isn't
it be alert be careful of what's
happening in your own Ward on this thank
you for that so now we go to seven in
questions under procedural rule a nine
and Sherlock has made four hands yeah
yeah yes a lot neater meet please cancel
the lock yeah sorry Fleming on the bland
[Music]
I'm afraid we can't hear you count sir
the lock now the kid MIT he came here
you came to look I'm afraid no no chair
okay we must move on then sure Marie yes
hmm
well yeah if I can respond to my written
quest to the answer to my written
question I'm slightly disappointed not
rarely of covering all my questions and
certain lack of urgency in the response
as well which doesn't reflect what ions
other people may feel about the local
plan may I ask you I think I'm allowed a
question yes
in response may we be assured that
rather than publishing it in the members
bulletin that the annual monitoring
report will be sent to all members
individually and the provision will be
made for their response to be debated at
a special full council meeting and I
would hope that there will be focused on
aspects of the local plan which require
urgent attention
right thank you thank you don't know
what you say about that well yeah well
as I say I think we need to get rid with
the officers to to sort out what the
well the issues are really and find the
best way forward really good bearing in
mind that the local plan is in
conjunction with north debt district as
well I think if we're going to have any
sort of review if we like then clearly
they need to be involved as well and
members yeah Shawn or Shawn will respond
okay
sure Thank You chair yeah they don't
process the review of local plan would
be started at the local plan working
group as you say which is a joint
working group with North Devon they they
have started considering that and and I
know it is an agenda item for a future
meeting
I've been did discussion with North
Devon about when that meeting might be
and as soon as I have a take I'll let
you know yeah it's all very concerned
that councillors don't have a better
more of an input into the local plan
really and I think we need that
opportunity basically that's what I'm
asking for it was there originally
members did have an opportunity in the
original drafting of the plan to make
representations but that was obviously
son but literally years ago so it's a
slow process where obviously things you
wish need you know that's not listed in
my question really affordable housing
climate change biodiversity and also the
allocation issue they're the ones which
concern me particularly alright well
thank you for that one will progress
that one right thank you
item eight is remote meetings procedure
rules and you've got a copy of that been
sent to you which is what the council
have have adopted
so Stacy I think is soon gonna lead on
this one
Thank You chair yes I've bought the
procedurals to the meeting tonight for
full council to finally consider and
formally adopt if they are in agreement
with them I mean hopefully by now all
members would have had the opportunity
to review them and they are simply to
allow members to attend meetings by
virtual means up until the 7th of May
2021 as all members will be aware up
until the implementation of the
coronavirus act 2020 it was a legal
requirement for members to physically
attend council meetings and the purpose
behind these regulations is to allow
members to attend meetings and for
council committee meetings to be
conducted via the virtual means whether
that's via Internet based solutions or
via telephone
I should just flag up at this stage that
we have moved on somewhat since we
originally drafted the regulations and
they were originally designed and with a
view to us not being in our normal
committee cycle and with a view to only
holding council meetings in an emergency
we have somewhat been released from the
lockdown restrictions that were in place
at the time but as it stands obviously
I'm happy to take any additional
questions that members may have on the
regulations thank you thank you very
much have we got any questions please
Aviv Eastham nuevo councillor Haynes and
councillor Jones for their hands happen
right thank you
go Saints umm yeah obviously we we have
to have rules covering this new
situation but I am I'm rather concerned
about some aspects of the rules first of
all
under three one that it appears meetings
whether we have meetings of committees
and things will be at the discretion of
the head of paid services and the leader
I'm very concerned about this I think we
should be getting back to a calendar of
meetings as possible and like parish
councils have been doing for instance
and this three three one seems to
conflict with the recommendation in the
report that council business should
carry on should be carried on with
committees and everything else and the
other concern I have is oh it's the same
one three one no it's not three three
sorry but we can't ask we can't ask
questions we can't put in notices of
motion that concerns me as well you know
I think these basically should be taken
out I don't think they should be there
well I can say is I'm totally agree we
are certainly on three three I can't see
any necessity for that we should be the
duck know our business as much as we can
in the corns with the way things were
done before I have to say that I was in
contact with my nephew over the weekend
dues of Birmingham city councillor and
asked him what they were doing or
firming and we're doing in and basically
they are continuing as much as possible
albeit virtually at this present time
but they have also got it written in
that when when they go back to normal
meetings again that these emerges once
immediately ceased and I think we should
do the same but in the meantime I would
be happy to second if you're proposing
to delete three three a thank you I mean
I'm pink yeah I mean as lead lead member
for climate I'm particularly concerned
that we're not getting on without for
instance and the other concern is it's
put down here that these these
provisions should be until May 2021
I mean are we gonna carry on like this
no no well that's the other other point
I want to raise is that we should have
it written in that we cease to follow
these this procedure the moment we're
back into full retail in Birmingham are
actually doing scrutiny or doing every
everything needed before albeit by the
internet Stephen Chow is going to ask
when I don't see we if we've now started
to move into having more regular
committee meeting so we've had a plans
committee meeting already we've got full
council tonight seeing our next week
another plans committee showed you for
next week both internal and external
scrutiny committees have had trial runs
by a zoom so we have kind of moved on to
having more regular committee meetings
so these were written as Stacy mentioned
at a time when we were under full
lockdown restrictions where the
expectation was that we'd have lots of
officers lots of members isolated and
obviously one of the things that hasn't
happened in this area is we've had a we
haven't had such a high infection raters
other areas across the country so whilst
we haven't had meetings we and we
haven't had to call meetings and we now
started to move forward into arranged in
regular scheduled committee meetings so
Stacy mentioned these were written at a
time when it was envisaged that would be
the case and it may be the case for it
may have been a case for a longer period
of time which hasn't happened so is
there any problem in deleting three
three a is that for example and also
putting a time limit or or at least
having the conditional time limit for
this this method of debate okay she's
going to come back okay thank you and
yes as it stands these regulations are
only in place until the 7th of May 2021
unless the government legislates further
so I anticipate am either before that
stage or by that stage we'll know
exactly where we are
in terms of the current pandemic
situation but as it stands they will
automatically fill up fall away on the
7th of May and we won't need to do
anything further and then I anticipate
that we will be back to our full normal
sheduled committee meetings with formal
attendance
unless you know the pandemic changes and
the government will legislate further
but they are only an interim measure at
this stage yeah but the point I'm making
is if if things are relaxed prior to
that date then surely that takes
precedence over these these procedure
rules here doesn't it if we have open
meetings yes so at this stage we need
the room open meeting regulations in
place worst were still holding virtual
meetings in this stage we're not in a
situation where we can do anything other
so happy to obviously accept suggestions
and amendments but we do need the
regulations in place whilst we're
conducting our council meetings in this
in this way which we have to at the
moment because we can't hold meetings
and public places priority then just for
clarity these regulations here our
government ones and we really have to
adopt them so they're really for noting
is that what you're saying so at the
moment our Constitution allows for
members to have to physically attend
meetings the government has legislated
to allow members to remotely attend and
it's sensible for us to adopt our own
procedure I have been discussing with
the Ebro monitoring offices across the
Devon authorities and we've tried to do
one that similar across the Devon
authorities and other authorities within
Devon have their committee structures
made up slightly different so with this
I've tried to do it so we amend our own
Constitution as little as possible other
than to allow us to call emergency
meetings and allowing members to attend
for actually
right okay so I would pose or I think
council houses really did that we do
delete three three a because I think the
important thing about Knossos motion the
cancers need to bring foot well can
bring for it is because it's it's one of
the major tools that you like of being a
cancer actually being able to put
forward and those emotion and that
that's really important to the
democratic process so really that that
should not be there and and we're off to
suck it and see obviously if it's abuse
and is a different matter isn't it but
at the end of the day the chair can
decide what notices motion accepts in
any case so one of the can't actually
have to have to accept them at term so
that can be deleted in my speak please
certainly Costa Newton I've had my
answer I've heard my hand up for a bit
could I just suggest that as we've heard
these regulations were obviously written
at a at a point of lockdown and are no
longer a apply as they are and there's
no transitionary arrangements at all in
these in these regulations that we're
obviously there has to be transitioning
rather rather than us hacking them about
tonight and proposing to take out this
or that perhaps we invite Stacy to
actually look again and to make them
more flexible so that they are actually
relevant because to my mind if we sign
up to these now irrespective of what is
said and I know Stacy has sent out a a
very explanatory email earlier on
however that counts for nothing because
if we adopt these regulations tonight
technically we are back we could be
bound by those we're just the leader
under head of paid service would when
make all the course well that's
obviously not the case
so rather than mucking them about
perhaps actually we shouldn't ask for
them to come back as a more useful set
of regulations which actually cover all
eventualities including the
transitionary period that we're now in
rather than a complete all or nothing
Thank You chair
Thank You Stacy if it was a response to
that yes Thank You counsel counsel the
Newton said is is very sensible and and
the reality of the situation is now is
that we are allowing notices of motion
as members will see there's one on the
agenda tonight in addition it is the
chairs of the committee's that are
calling meetings and we have been gazing
with them in relation to their own
individual meetings I could say the
reason that the regulations were first
drafted for the leader and had a paid
service to call the meetings was because
we just didn't know the extent of the
pandemic who would be available and
obviously we needed the ability to be
able to call committee meetings urgently
so but we have adapted now and we are
you know the council never held his
plans committee the chairs of intend on
ons are holding their committees and
councillor Brenton tonight you're
dealing with full council so I think as
council new term sensibly says the
reality is we have moved on and I can
change the rules now to adapt to the
current situation and really and
predominantly and the major point is to
allow us to be able to hold committee
meetings virtually and that's that's the
crucial crucial part well it seems to me
so deferment is the is the way forward
in fact to have these amended or
deferred and then amended really rather
than both on these tonight which would
actually affect our Constitution so
right yeah you've got three more
countenances hands out councillor hurry
and cancel hangs okay so Joe's first one
yes thank you yeah I'd like to say I'd
like to second what council Newton said
and I think that these as we say are
something which have got to be there and
we need to have them there for the
worst-case scenario type situation but
as he says I think Stacey can go back
and look at these and imbue them with a
bit more flexibility
and on an on an alternative view though
we're all talking about getting getting
back to normal and having meetings again
in person but while this government
legislation is in place but for us to be
able to have meetings remotely perhaps
something like full council is rather
more tricky but perhaps while we can
still do it maybe we should be looking
at holding all of our committees
remotely for saving members time and
obviously helping with our pledge
towards the environment because we're
not all having to travel with a bit of
food just a thought
thank you
sorry yes really right Thank You chair I
just like to reiterate what's been said
more than once these rules were written
some time ago and we have moved on quite
substantially since then I believe
Stacy's email last Friday cleared up a
lot of points but members of minded for
states to go away and rewrite them so
the RSU written down that's probably a
good point to to go to thank you Jim
thank you it was the other one the Hanks
and cancel another thank you yeah well
yes having saw go you know I was going
to propose so we delete the two clauses
actually but I'll go along with what
you've suggested as a sensible routes
but yeah I mean just point out that that
these regulations as far as I can see
where we were not obliged to follow
these rules we can we can we can
actually do our own rules they're not
laid down by government as I understand
it and secondly as again as I'm lead
member for climate change obviously I'm
extremely concerned that this council
needs to get on with preparing its
climate plan and I as chair of the
working group I would like to have a
meeting as soon as possible so I hope
within these rules as we have them at
the moment we can do that very very soon
thank you very much attention leather
Thank You Chad yeah well I was going
looking through these rules of procedure
if you read them all through I think
it's only three three point one little
brackets a and three point three little
brackets hey that need to be removed the
rest of it looks fine to me
and paint counselor Haynes was going to
propose that those two are removed I'd
like to propose that those two are
removed and the rest are fine
sorry okay so it does appear that the
way things are at the moment there's a
review of the whole of these would not
come miss really so I would go with
counselor Newton Rooney and think that
Stacy's go away and and redraft them to
a to a more sort of accommodating time
so would you two counsel sue paint and
leather would you withdraw your proposal
in light of the fact that we could
review these we won't take a boat on
these tonight he could leave so we need
not be committed to them tonight we can
defer them to the next meeting after
we've had them room redrafted would you
be happy with that
well well Terry if you look at the
headings throughout it's more or less in
line with our Constitution anyway yeah
the majority the quorum declarations of
interest method of voting member access
to meetings it's all there more or less
in in line with our Constitution reading
them I can't think as I said what needs
changing about apart from omitting those
two that I proposed some council hem
seconded
I guess if I could just add something if
that's okay
yeah estación a couple of other members
have mentioned these are written in a
time when we were in an emergency
situation and during those times it
could quite easily be envisaged that the
chair and or vice chair of any committee
or council could be or could have been
isolated or ill from the virus so that's
the way that's the reason those
particular items were put in to allow
things to continue in the absence of
chairs of committees once we understand
yes we have moved on so we can remove
them that's not to say something might
happen through a second wave or second
spike whatever you wish to term it
that's something like that would need to
be put back in place so it's to cover
all those eventualities it wasn't sure
and if take control of over meetings and
things like that it was to cover the
council in case we needed all the meet
in and the chairs of committees were
unavailable now obviously we have moved
on we have in a full council meeting
tonight so items are on notice emotions
and questions are now incorporated so a
lot of this is and a retrospective we've
had in place to deal with the what could
have been the major event of a pandemic
which fortunately torij didn't have such
an impact that's the reason why all of
those things are a kind of a kind of in
in the report and in the procedure notes
right
care you've got canceled Magoffin
counselor Newton with a hand up right
yeah sure Magoffin very nice mr.
chairman I just obviously just like to
move back to the council Newton he
proposed this deferment and councilor
Jones you seconded it oh she missed her
stops in a few key points there but you
know to make sense is the third is bring
it back to the next meeting and just to
move on please Jim all right just a
second speaker there's the other one
okay so no Newton chair sorry Canton in
Newton to cancel Newton sorry no sir
usual just just if I may coming back on
on what's been said if you remove the
two sub paragraphs which is being
suggested as an alternative all you're
doing is actually making the regulations
fit for today but if we have a spike in
a pandemic again and more severe
measures have to be taken then we'd have
to revisit the regulations again because
they wouldn't they wouldn't be suitable
by then what I'm saying is make them
more flexible which can then cover all
eventualities from the worst case right
way through to normalization in an
emergency and and then that covers all
all all aspects of it I'm just trying to
propose that we Stacy revises it to make
it a more useful and relevant which has
a little bit more sort of endurance in
it because it'll last two different
circumstances thank you yeah well I'm
going to take a vote on your proposal
and it was saying it by who was it John
Doe jang taejeong okay Jones was the
second there is that right yeah and
Newton was living because they do have
to bear in mind that you know please
stop we don't get a second strike or
anything really bad necessary sometimes
it cancels to take some tough decisions
and they have to be taken by somebody so
we need to have that written in in some
way as to who that those persons should
be so I'm gonna take a vote on it so
well sander if you would go through the
list please
yes chair Stacy re-examine them and
bring back pressure well not totally
press a new set of proposals
alright revised revised set of proposals
yeah
Thank You chair cancel abouton for
Chancellor Brenton or counselor bright
or cancel Bushby or counselor Christy Oh
hence the Clark Kents Nakata honking OH
cancer Dart
she not that's okay four four thank you
cancer Ford or actually girl for
counselor Hackett for cancer Harding
cancel Halloween for penciler homes and
sorry against councillor Hawkins it's a
hippo for cancer the Hicks or Hanson oh
it's early cancer Hutchins
Oh hence the inch for Hensley James or
Nancy Jones
or cancer laws or cancer Langford for
Hansel 1100 cancer McKenzie for captain
Amman Lee oh that's Anna Newton or pence
the Pennington or
Rossi for cancer Watson oh and cancel
Wiseman all thank you cancers one
abstention
oh one again sorry Thank You Sandra
well Stacy I think you've got the flavor
from the debate of what's required and
then we look for do reported next
meeting thank you so now we go on to
item nine which is the Westeros slipway
extension and and I would ask councillor
Hudson if she would like to lead on this
one please my good evening everybody
um it gives me great pleasure to
introduce this very comprehensive report
to commend the work of the offices such
a detailed presentation you've often
heard me what lyrical about westward ho
and how important this coastal resort is
to the economy of torrid but tonight I'm
able to send an immediate solution which
is both affordable and can be delivered
for this summer provide access to the
beach for any member of the community of
torij both the local people and visitors
alike
secondly the report details proposals
for interim measures to make the
porridge more resilient to the power of
the sea to provide a level of protection
to produce risk of flooding there were
to be a further preach this winter
therefore proposed to members you
continued
give us support this project folk night
all the recommendations in this report
I'd like to with the permission of the
chair and over two counts and the laws
who has fought tirelessly for find a
solution for slipway as well from him on
many occasions so as Lee Benton can I
ask providing he wants to speak you may
not want to does cancelosi wish to add
your words of wisdom
not so much wisdom just a little
enlightenment for the actual members in
very simplistic terms just understand
the situation
last summer I witnessed something that I
found quite upsetting really for an
elderly couple very elderly couple
coming to conquest with her on holiday
and they literally toggled on this slip
way and it could not walk on to the
beach and they don't you either forger
the problem has been known for a long
time but what you have to understand is
that you don't need always a huge Gale
you can go down there are one one
evening and the next morning the beach
would have appeared to have just dropped
two feet and it can drop to an extent
that I've got a bit of arthritis I
actually have to sit on the end of the
slipway and lower myself down onto the
onto the pebbles and then onto the beach
the actual tide and it doesn't have to
be a gale moves thousands and thousands
of tons of sand on a tide it's very
volatile the difficulty has been in and
it's difficult for our officers to
because if you ask Adrian to build you
you know a new business complex it's
factual it's there
levels making constructive this is
caused for much more thought and it's
only a little tiny thing it's just 30
feet of concrete effectively but it's
concentrated to mind and I know Chris
Wilson whose excellent officer
very passionate has actually spent hours
just looking at wave action because it
actually hits the seawall and then it
comes back at all sorts of weird angles
and it's been very difficult but they've
worked really hard on this they've had
to get all the agencies together and it
gives me great pleasure to to the second
it the aura second part of the situation
chair is much more complicated Adrian I
expect can explain that to you the
weakening of the beverage of the
Westwood her end but the slipway will
now not just be an extension to the
slipway it's going to go down through
the sand and be embedded in the clay
below the beach so however little sand
or however much that you'll be able to
walk down and walk onto the beach right
bank a dream Thank You chair thank you
so your seconded it so John there are
any other speakers yes chair you've got
paint Lorraine can cancel a Haines to
the hand up right there each first
didn't think there's a means Thank You
chairman through the post some of the
white is not very clear on there anyway
but I was just wondering you know we've
all seen this rock are murdering their
boo-boos and bigger stones in what rock
armor they've got there I just I'm just
wondering will this work because I'm not
very convinced that it will actually the
type of storms that were getting at this
there is quite tremendous and I'm just
wondering whether
Harbor is quite enough I I've got my
types actually but I don't know who
designed it is it it is it been designed
by an engineer or a musician you know
coach sir law says that thousands of
tons of sounds sound is moving each
other and this probably means that this
rock arm will be moved as well I just
don't want to see this pencil sort of
come back next year with egg on his face
saying oh this this isn't this hasn't
worked I just thought if Adrian can sort
of convinced me I'd like to like to hear
from them
Thank You chair right thank you it's
even they're torn over yes very nice
yeah okay could you quickly respond to
that done Adrian and work basically who
designed it is it is an engineer that's
done it the work has been designed
chaired by our coastal engineer and our
consulting engineers John Grimes
partnership who've together come up with
this scheme for the slipway extension
the rock armor that's proposed at the
the actual end of the slipway extension
is actually intended for scour
protection and that basically means that
it will reduce the amount of wash around
the actual toe of the slipway so that
hopefully there will be less opportunity
for the material Beach material to be
removed if the rock armor was too big it
would actually create more scour at the
end we're having it shallow and on the
sides of the slipway it's intended that
the sand will remain at the base there
are occasions when the sand will
hopefully cover the rock armour
completely because you'll know that on
occasions and it does actually come part
way up the slipway so the rock the rock
Omar is really scour protection that's
all thank you very much Adrian Haines
yes thank you very much sure yeah it's
great that some some action is at last
being taken about this this
problem that has two things is that this
is as I understand is this an interim
solution and so if so is how long is it
perceived to last we're given the rising
sea-levels
into the future and secondly what not
quite clear what the provision is for
alternative routes on to the beach when
this is being constructed
perhaps Adrienne could answer that I'm
gonna answer that one Adrienne what
alternative you can do half-and-half or
what what you gonna do to get so people
get on the beach while it's being done
okay chair thank you two valid points
first of all this is this is not not a
sort of interim measure this extension
will be there for the long term
obviously it's taken down into the clay
and it will be there until such time as
the Environment Agency decide that it's
no longer necessary as part of their
larger scheme for the linear defense but
the intentions are at the moment that it
will be incorporated into that scheme in
some fashion so that that's that first
question in terms of access to the beach
access to the beach is going to be a
challenge during the course of the works
and that's why we've selected this
particular type of construction to
minimize the time on site in doing the
work we've been in discussions with the
are an ally to ensure that they will
still have access onto the beach during
the period and they will achieve that
that sounded me a bridge where we will
be slightly widening the access
therefore they're 4x4 vehicles in the
event of emergency access that's
required for this period and similarly
public access will be encouraged through
social media at Sandy Mia on to the
beach anyone else meaning to gain access
at Westward Ho End will need to use the
the steps and other access points at the
village end of the beach but we
obviously want to discourage people from
trying to access the beach during these
works for various you know safety
reasons Walsall work is in progress run
roughly how long will that take it works
at the moment we're expecting it to take
two weeks if we start in the middle of
July and on eight use of the slack tides
we should get it done in two weeks
thank you right if there's no more John
I'll take the bus being canceled to hire
any character and possibility there's a
push beef campaign you came to the puppy
I'm you know better that's it Thank You
chair I'm quite happy to support the
extension of the slipway that's clearly
needed I have got some concerns
regarding the the rest of the the works
to reinforce the actual beverage current
comes to Hammes
ask the question just now is this an
interim solution I would say yes it is
very much an interim solution it doesn't
matter what you do down on the pond the
pebble reach it will require regular
maintenance Rock armor yes it's a great
thing it does move her own and it does
need some engineering or an annual basis
to to reinforce it with the addition of
some pebbles as well but I mean the
pebbles that appear to be depleted on
the on the pebble Ridge you haven't got
enough mounted they haven't gone you
know then you know removed from the
beach area they're on the beach in
different places where in my opinion
they're not doing an awful lot of good
and it's if those pebbles could be
removed from where they are doing those
actually put into the pebble Ridge were
they will do you know a heap of good
that's you know that's what they that's
where that's what needs to be done on an
annual basis so I think yes it is a
temporary solution but I think torrid
you really do have to commit to doing
works on the beverage on an annual basis
along the lines that they did a year
prior to 2000 when they when they used
to have a biannual reach our program you
know the problems that we're seeing now
or because that process was abandoned in
2000 and little or no work has been done
since then so I'm happy to support
what's been proposed now but you know I
would urge councilors to realize that
Tories will will have to commit
resources probably on an annual basis to
reinforce recharge those weak areas of
the beverage thank you
sorry to lose the next person came to
the Harley then came to the McKenzie jet
right close rahuri Thank You chair
I mean look leaders to report this is
the only way forward to actually
allowing people to go onto the beach
it's something I've looked at for some
time it's rarely been reported cancer
laws just said the main thing the main
problem course is the sand the amount of
sand that comes and goes at present the
slipway is fine if the sand doesn't move
but once the sand goes nobody can
actually get onto the beach so I would
fully support this to allow people to
get on the beach and the only way you
can actually allow that is to actually
go effectively beneath the sand so
whatever level of standards people can
still go onto the beach so all in favor
of this thank you Jeff thank you so
councillor McKenzie next yeah I think
this is a great thing in a very good
start as I understand it if you
strengthen the sea defences around the
slipway at the extreme edge of those
defenses becomes a weak point and a
point where the sea can do more damage
accelerate it damage to the pebble Ridge
beyond the rock honor so you know
there'll be great to have access to the
beach but how long will the beach
survive if the beverage is breached you
know and we've got you know new
properties we've got a visitor center
that could be at risk from the tight why
sad a if the pebble Ridge is breached
and you know you're gonna be throwing
things out to try and shore up the
pebble Ridge it's a great start in
February needs more thought for its
entire length you know I don't like the
natural england
approach to it of letting nature
take its course because you know it's a
very big money spin of West for though
[ __ ] for couture each it makes over a
million pounds a year and if that's
destroyed by breaches in the pattern
rich then it's a lot of money gone it's
you know it's going to have a massive
effect on the estuary they will have a
massive effect on Biddy fit into and
bounce to believe in and you know we
could end up with lots of fun along the
estuary in the rivers which could lead
to environmental refugees thank you okay
John is that came to the her knees no
they turned up again chair all right
well I'll indulge it for a second I
thank you very much chair I appreciate
that
I fully support the council Mackenzie
said the big problem here is natural
England they decided they'd let the
whole boroughs go back to to its natural
ways if you like and stop protecting the
ridge they as I see it on the big
problem thank you
just as a footnote I noticed when we had
the pleasure of being on the met some of
those coastal places get terrific storms
there's people know that Macon will be
really bad and they make these
interlocking like Jack's remember Jax's
children you played with in a playground
interlocking concrete and Auntie wave
structures and they're really really
effective much better than Rock armor
but of course they cost money so I don't
know what how feasible they are onsen
proposed it and was seconded by
Councillor laws so those in favor of the
recommendations which are found on sorry
where is it page 26 of your agenda the
recommendation five of the three
recommendations here correct you're
proposing yes thank you goes a little
second II yes
okay so Luther's about then those in
favor
please indicate the sander when she asks
Thank You chair thanks Ana Banton four
counts and a brenton or tents and a
bright for pencil a brown lawn cancel a
bush be or can't snow Christie or hence
the Clark or that's the cut of honking
or pencil a dart for pencil afford or
pencil a cab for it's the Hackett poor
councillor Harding for pencil Hames orb
it's the Hawkins oh that's a hippo for
that's the Hicks
[Music]
thanks for Hanson Oh pencil Haley or
Hutchins
oh that's the wrench for pencil James or
pencil Jones or pencil in laws or pencil
in Lankford for hats no led there or
hemlock or pencil Emma golf or cancer
McKenzie Paul Henson a manly or Hanson a
Newton sorry I didn't hear that
for sorry cancer Pennington or penciler
Rossi for cancer Watson
oh that's the wise men or that's
unanimous chair thank you very much
dancers so item 10 treasury management
counterparty limits so steep you're
leaving on this one trail be to Mitch
Hayes sorry David
okay I think members have be pleased to
hear there isn't a vote on this item
yeah the treasury management policies
agreed by full Council which lays down
the rules of how we invest our surplus
cash just give you some highlights of
that we have to invest our money in
Fitch 1f 1 rated uk-based Institute
financial institutions the maximum we
can hold it when in one institution is 5
million pounds and the maximum placement
we can do is three million pounds
separately treasury management policy
also says that which can hold up to 8
million pounds in our current bank
account which is with Lloyds afternoon
farm members that we breached our
treasury management policy on the 1st of
April when the central government
thirty-five million pounds into our bank
accounts and this money was to support
businesses by us with the administrator
on their behalf for business support
grants and to date we've spent twenty
six million pounds of that grant and was
processing of over 1.3 million pounds of
application for digression discretionary
business to support the issue is that
we've got money in our bank account that
we don't know where when the government
may reclaim the bounds that we've not
spent so we were in breach of it on day
one on the 1st of April and we're doing
our best we can to stay within the
Treasury monitor policy at the time
being at this moment in time we've got
more than 8 million powers in our bank
account as of today it's just simply for
members to know that right thank you for
that any questions
no thank you right thank you very much
just for noting then councilors so move
to item 10
sorry 11 petitions and I think we have
got one every John okay yet chair yes we
did receive one on on Friday it's with
the Democratic Services team to validate
and process in accordance with our
petition scheme so it hasn't come
forward in time for tonight's full
council meeting we need to determine how
that's dealt with it's in relation to
drop our charges okay thank you for that
so now I can 12 there's a notice of
motion council McGough if you'd like to
state your case for your notice of
motion I will then ask for a second
there okay mr. chairman which let me
read out or is everyone there's all
noticeable yeah we've got it in front of
us I think right obviously the main
thing is trying to get support from the
councilors I've spoken to several
captors privately trying to get support
for this motion I think it's the right
thing for tourist encounters to do to
support our business communities from
our town centers as it says an emotion
but the fine detail obviously will lay
with community resources where we can
actually give an offset a full written
detail of the finances of the district
counts and what cost it would be to us
but I'm not going to change any wording
as you see is what it is and I don't
want to get too messy as the community
resources can then thoroughly go for it
Thank You mr. chairman thank you so I've
got a seconder for that - no motion
please I'll second that
so Rossi is seconding it so really this
is a notice of motion that will go see
in our for a report if approved by
councillors so nobody wishes to - I've
got some hand up I don't know if you
didn't want to write who's who's caught
- honking came slinking Casey oh my god
right okay the
counselor Carl honking and please hi so
I just wanted to second there are you
beaten to it by councillor Rossi okay I
know thanks for that so the next one was
councillor inch I think is that right
thank you sure how I was gonna second it
as well I just think that we should be
doing this all right
you know with the amount of reserves
we've got they've they have they're
there for a reason they're there for a
right who's who's a third one then
you've got thankfully my golf game
supposed to be in case they're
Pennington right I'm sir Goff okay thank
you mr. chairman all it was I'd like to
see this if we can some way to get it
off so I speak to mr. Hicks made a chair
of some stuff finance the community
resources sorry to see if we can get
this on Mondays agenda as in like a
motor item because I think it's very
important and actually touches on MIDI I
think there's a petition went in several
days after my motion went forward and it
would actually coincide maybe not fully
what the petition says okay well that's
up to the chair of seeing are ready to
deal with that one sorry who was an
excellent John I didn't speak a little
Bush be you hear me yes thank you John
yes I happy to support this motion and
but clearly you know times are really
tough for the traders in the town and we
don't need any delay in this so does it
have to go to seeing her as we're in
full council or can we not make that
decision now and bypass focus and the
CNR meeting because I thinking of it the
traders don't want to go another week or
a fortnight you know we're limited
numbers of shoppers coming into the time
and if it's known that you know for the
next two months we've got free free
parking it could help them
well as I understand it cancel push me
it does have to go to CN or for the
financial implication so that's where it
will go before codes you can't override
now no okay Tyler Pennington chair
cancer pension yes sure thank you is a
petition no did that mean Cody council
because they do all the street parking
in many areas of our our district as
well it's not just our car parts at
orange but the Stefan County parking on
on Street are we going to petition Devon
County Thank You chair right well I
presume that would be something you'd be
discussed at seeing are to have some
sort of unity with the county council
but it's at the moment this this is the
Pope is going to decide whether it goes
to seeing are or not who's the other one
John was there anybody else after cancer
pension counselor Hurley now ice under
it
okay cuz her hurry here Thank You chair
I don't believe this will make any
difference the town's whatsoever looking
at Steve's report this evening talking
about when he spoke the LGA was it today
I believe Steve and we're by asking the
government to support Council with the
amount of money who's spent and the
government's basically saying it's up to
cancel or to make honey right now on
that basis under all of this money has
to concrete but ordered it's a notice of
motion we're not meant to debate this
no no way yeah she's true but debating
I'm just giving my point of view that's
all they're not those emotion okay you
can't you couldn't speak about why it
shouldn't go to see you know hora well I
don't believe it's worth doing be honest
I'll not leave their their trip okay so
the next one is counselor leather I
think is that right cave got counselor
Christy and counselor it was just it was
using sorry Costa Christian name was
chopped off so just Chris on there
counselor Christy thank you
yes I find this fairly odd because I
don't suppose the rest of the counselors
outside a bit of all realize that Devon
County Council have actually taken away
some of our free parking on our street
parking it's been taken away and the
reason given is they're trying to get
more people to walk and now I hear Tory
saying we want to get free biking so
more people can drive in it seems a bit
odd actually and this is something that
I think we ought to look at can I ask
when this does come to seeing are the
four figures will be available because
whenever I get asked about free parking
I always have to point out that if you
give free parking the money has to come
from somewhere else keep the car parks
everything else and what it boils down
to is that those people without a car
and luck subsidizing those people with a
car and I think this needs to be brought
out when he comes and discusses see you
no thank you right okay thank you for
that counselor next yeah I didn't
realize that people were gonna be able
to speak about the emotion and I wrote
down some things because they're
planning to second it before councillor
Rossi and second before me so there's
wondering whether I could read out well
it's really you could speak against the
motion not going to see an R obviously
it is up for debate on that one is but
really the if the gist of what the
arguments will be at the end of the day
should really be said at seeing our I
don't think we'd need to pre rehearse it
here if at all if you're content with
that okay I will say I thought that we
could keep a previous meeting you were
able to chain make a vote which it was
about the cattle market and that was you
councillor Brendan yes yes the votes
take place but now you're not allowing
it to take place and we see it as a
mergency I slipped that
the wire basically because it was a
health and safety issue at the time so
that was a slightly different argument
really but where are their financial
implications to the revenue of the
council and really we have to put it to
the appropriate committee they could
also be argued that this is health and
safety of a corona virus pandemic at the
moment and people having to use beans at
the car parts a good try
okay if I could say if I could add some
I could add something I think even the
item of the cattle market went to see an
R so that report still went to see a
half of a final approval the items that
you normally vote on is us was the case
at the last whole council meeting if
it's simply a letter go into another
organization their members are showing
their support to doing that whereas sure
you've indicated this needs financial
implications right I'm going to go to
the vote now because into a debate that
should take place at scene are so those
in favor of the notice of motion please
indicate Sandra when she calls your name
Thank You chair canceled about turn at
for Chancellor Brenton or that's the
bright for council a brown or that's the
bunch be or Kent's no Christy it's a
Clark let's look at a honking Oh pants
no dart or hence the Ford or insula cab
or and a Hackett for ensign Harding or
pencil Holmes abstain okay Hawkins for
captain the hippo before cancer the
Hicks
parents and Hicks for pencil Hudson all
pencil Haley against cancer Hutchins
oh that's their inch for tensley James
or pencil Jones for Chancellor laws for
leather or pencil anak all for McKenzie
against councillor manly or counselor
Newton the Pennington or Rossi for three
I think
sorry cancel Watson I didn't catch it
okay counselor Wiseman oh that's two
abstentions - chair - against 34 thank
you very much
so that goes to seeing our thank you the
check yes I asked you a question please
yes sir just regarding just as that
motion was being read out I am I send a
message to John Walter I could second it
I put my hand up three times during the
course of the meeting as how are we
supposed to be getting on so we can
actually say something because I'm
obviously doing something wrong right
okay well then that's jaw water better
because the participant came to hurt
change it's right under participants on
your screen yeah
raise hand if you press that then that
comes on to the chair screen up to the
offices screen as well so anybody watch
that raises a hand equality apologies I
did realize you had you didn't realize
that
thank you do want to try that you know
I'm there I'll get us thinking I was
raising my hand in my on my camera not
on this not in there
oh okay all right thank you for that so
now I pose that we move into part two do
we have to go through a BOTY procedure
again Sandra yes chair sorry
all right we'll get used to this
proposal we go into court to offset not
sure all right so one reader may then
please all right Thank You chair close
to the baton for councillor Brenton Oh
parents knob right oh that's the brown
that's the bush be or thanks the Christy
or Clark or cancel Cottle honking that's
the dart 4x afford for it's a cab for
that's the heck it or it's the harding
for it's the homes or X or the Hawkins
for that's the Hicks we can't hang okay
so hit for I keep getting
Hudson Oh or actions
oh it's an inch for pencil Oh James for
pencil ooh Jones or pencil nemours Oh
pants lalang food for Hanson a leather
or pencil in lock all or pencil McKenzie
oh that's a manly or pencil Newton's
cancer Pennington or pencil or OC for
there's no Watson oh and cancel Weisman
oh that's unanimous chair thank you very
much
dance this so part two the first item is
number thank you sorry can I just have
some time back to get more YouTube yes
thank you
we have to say goodbye to you thank you
for watching